Oh
since the early days of life on earth
our little planet has been on the
receiving end of a number of unfortunate
cataclysms beginning about 439 million
years ago there have been five major
extinction events each of which
eradicated a sizable portion of Earth's
life forms and many suspect we're
currently living in the sixth major
extinction whereas the previous
extinction events were caused primarily
by volcanic activity and asteroid
impacts our current era has seen a
dramatic increase in individual species
extinctions between 10 and 100 times
faster than normal
caused predominantly by human activity
affecting the global climate scientists
report that plants and animals are dying
off at an alarming rate and if that
trend continues we could face our very
own mass extinction event in the
not-too-distant future assuming the
wheels of extinction are already set in
motion how could we protect biodiversity
and earth life as we know it could we
somehow create a backup of the entire
earth like some kind of biological hard
drive to answer that question let's take
a look at the main problems facing life
on Earth in the event of a mass
extinction in the case that the
extinction is caused by climate change
we could expect many biomes to become
uninhabitable over the course of several
years or decades while this is a big
problem we would still likely have time
to gather critical genetic material and
live specimens of most plant and animal
species in affected areas for storage
and eventual repopulation the thinking
here is that these affected biomes could
eventually be returned to a habitable
state whether through scientific efforts
or simple passage of time if however the
extinction were triggered by an asteroid
impact or other single catastrophe it's
unlikely that any complex life would
survive and the entire earth could
potentially be rendered uninhabitable
for many decades or centuries making
off-site storage a necessity archiving
and maintaining genetic material from
every living species on earth would be a
tremendous undertaking and could very
well prove to be impossible but we can
look to current preservation endeavors
to get an idea of just how feasible a
whole earth backup would be take for
example the spell barred global Seed
Vault
located near the North Pole this Arctic
storage facility contains the largest
collection of agricultural biodiversity
yet assembled designed to protect
valuable crops and plant species in the
event of global disaster this Doomsday
vault currently contains over 9
thirty thousand samples the goal of the
Svalbard Seed Vault is not to be an
emergency stockpile of seeds in case the
farmers of the world run out but rather
to be a bank of genetic diversity
lending seeds to scientists and farmers
trying to develop new disease resistant
varieties or subspecies that can thrive
in new more difficult climates to use
our hard drive example the Svalbard Seed
Vault houses thousands of Microsoft Word
templates ready to be opened edited and
saved as new files on our new computer
as promising as the Doomsday vault is
even this Arctic stronghold is not
completely safe from the effective
climate change
in early 2017 unusually high
temperatures paired with heavy rainfall
caused a slight intrusion of water near
the vaults entrance as global
temperature increases the viability of
the frozen seeds could be compromised
and ruin the entire project that brings
us to the main obstacle to overcome in
creating a perfect backup off-site
storage for most backups you can simply
copy your files to an external drive and
take that drive to another location in
case of a house fire or electrical
failure but what happens when the
computer is the entire earth where could
we save our files that would be safe
from disaster on a planet-wide scale the
obvious answer would be outer space
simply away from the computer to use our
analogy but logistically speaking that
would be quite a challenge
a giant biological vault on the moon or
free floating space station would likely
prevent its immediate destruction from
earth-based catastrophe like an asteroid
impact but the frozen seeds and genetic
material would probably be subjected to
large doses of radiation rendering them
damaged or completely ruined so far
we've seen that seeds can survive at
least six months in space but there have
been relatively few studies another
problem is keeping the specimen
sufficiently frozen if the freezing
methods fail the hard drives precious
cargo will be destroyed on the other
hand remaining frozen for too long could
damage or destroy the specimens so far
we've only seen animal sperm eggs and
embryos that have been frozen for about
twenty years to be viable any longer
than that and we'd be an uncharted
territory another potentially
insurmountable problem is that a space
station or moon vault backup would
likely have to rely on genomic data
instead of actual biological material
from each animal species on earth
save on space and resources having sperm
eggs and embryos in addition to live
surrogate mothers is one thing but
creating a living animal from just a
sequence genome would be an enormous
challenge and would rely on future
advances in the fields of medicine and
biology
assuming we had this backup in place if
an asteroid impact rendered the earth
uninhabitable for say 200 years we'd
still have to contend with the probable
lack of human populations available to
repopulate the planet how many people
would be required to safely rebuild
humanity's numbers without sacrificing
genetic diversity one geneticist studied
a similar problem which was the question
what is the optimal crew size for a
generation ship this optimal number was
considered the smallest crew that could
maintain acceptable genetic diversity
during the ship's 10 generation voyage
for a journey of eight to ten
generations or about 200 years his
calculation suggested that a minimum of
160 people would be needed to maintain a
stable relatively healthy population
however he goes on to say that this
would only be possible if the crew were
reintroduced to a larger population with
greater genetic diversity or had access
to a fertilized egg Bank at the end of
the voyage so if we wanted to be sure
that we could rebuild humanity and
reintroduce all the species of flora and
fauna to our post extinction earth we
would require a space backup of at least
160 genetically diverse humans a large
diverse fertilized egg Bank
massive stores of seeds and animal
genetic material or huge archives of the
genomic data of every species on earth
is it possible in theory yes it would be
hugely expensive and require the most
effort and man-hours in the broadest and
most overarching archival endeavor in
history but it could be done assuming
everything went according to plan of
course we just have to hope that the
formatting on older hard drive is
compatible with our post extinction
Earth if you enjoyed this video make
sure to subscribe to keep up to date
with the latest content and leave a
comment down below with your thoughts on
making a backup of the entire earth you
can watch my previous video by clicking
here or watch all my videos by clicking
here don't forget to follow second
thought on your favorite social media
and check out the new combined second
thought and real-life lore Instagram
where we share pictures of our
adventures and daily life thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video